and so it's design week here on the show
and we wanted to see
what you all find aesthetically pleasing
and if you'll show us one cool thing
from your house that's one cool thing
um okay jamie you're at your home in
london will you show us one cool thing
in your house
yeah okay
so that's like a funky uh do we call
that a pendant like i don't know
it's um it's a lot going on it feels
like a sort of
futuristic like space spider thing
and it hangs in our kitchen does it
spark joy
yeah every day there you go okay annie
your turn will you show us one cool
thing and tell us why you like it
um okay
oh oh my gosh
yes
he is a big [ __ ] that lives in my
kitchen yes
[Applause]
um his name is carmine
yeah um i have a thing for like
i like chickens and roosters in my
kitchen
that's so like you and everyone else in
america
he's not the only one he's not the only
guy there are others but this is the guy
that made
made the segment i love it kristin
you're up do you have one cool thing you
could show us
i do i have a a pillow that
is old and it's like a cross stitch
pillow
that i oh yeah those are zippers
but i take this with me when i
like go to not like for dinner but like
that would be really weird if i show up
i'm like i'm gonna put this on my chair
um no i like if i like run a house or
something
i bring this with me because i i love
this pillow it's like come sit down
yeah i don't yeah
i swear i don't know how to put into
words but
i i have an animal thing where i i just
gives me a feeling and i
i understand that pillow and it's
awesome and
um i know for anyone um who needs
um a boost and joy and goodness
needs to go see barb and star go to
vista del mar
so thank you guys so much for coming and
talking about this
epic odyssey that you guys made
really and truly that's so sweet
thank you thank you so true kristen wiig
annie mummelo and jamie
dornan barb and star go to vista del mar
is now available to rent and you can own
it on march 26th
thank you guys so much for stopping by
in your busy day i'm so grateful
to talk to you really thanks true thanks
[Applause]
guys
[Music]
you